ma question porte sur les mineur isolé
d'origine étrangère qui errent en bande
dans paris et bordeaux et commettent des
délits
ce phénomène est apparu il ya trois ans
à paris dans le quartier de la goutte
d'or depuis il s'est progressivement
étendue à la banlieue est désormais à
bordeaux
ce phénomène prend de plus en plus
d'ampleur sans que les pouvoirs publics
arrivent talent endiguer ces mineurs
sont pour la plupart polytoxicomane très
violent et spécialisée dans les vols et
les agressions en 2018 5989 mineurs
isolés ont été arrêtés par la préfecture
de police à paris et en petite couronne
il s'agit essentiellement de garçons
nous savons que la situation est
complexe
les mineurs étrangers sont d'abord des
enfants et ses enfants sont avant tout
des victimes avant d'être des
délinquants
on s'interroge encore sur l'existence de
réseaux criminels qui jetterait ses
enfants dans les rues en les droguant
afin qu'ils commettent des vols pour
alimenter des circuits de revente les
associations et la justice ont leur
possible pour leur venir en aide
nous ne devons pas céder au fatalisme et
à la résignation
notre responsabilité politique et
d'apporter des réponses pour aider ces
jeunes en errance pour lutter contre les
agressions et pour abattre les réseaux
qui les utiliseraient aussi monsieur le
ministre je souhaiterais savoir si le
gouvernement entend mettre en oeuvre un
cadre d'action national pour aider ces
jeunes en errance et pour lutter contre
la délinquance qui ont découlent
merci la parole est à m e marc fesneau
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice voudrais vous remercier de
votre question de la façon dont vous
l'abordez parce que comme vous l'avez
rappelé c'est une question extrêmement
complexe
le phénomène que vous décrivez est connu
et d'habré a d'abord émergé dans la
capitale vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs avec
l'arrivée de nombreux mineurs dont déjà
un certain nombre d'origine marocaine et
c'est ce qu'on sait cette population là
pour le retrouve à bordeaux dès la
connaissance de ce phénomène nous avons
pris la tâche avec les pays de départ
nhs afin d'obtenir notamment des
informations sur ces personnes
je peux par ailleurs vous dire qu'une
coopération renforcée déjà d'ores et
déjà à l'oeuvre avec le ministre de la
justice sur ce sujet coopération qui
nous a permis de judiciariser de
nombreux cas lorsque les faits le
justifier ça c'est la réponse judiciaire
en conséquence grâce à la coopération
avec les pays et celle constante avec la
justice nous avons obtenu des résultats
probants sur le renvoi de séminaires
dans leur pays d'origine que quand ça
devait relever de cette procédure
l'action du ministre de l'intérieur
s'est par ailleurs concentrer sur la
lutte contre les trafics d'êtres humains
et plus particulièrement vous l'avez
évoqué sur le démantèlement des réseaux
la lutte contre les filières de passeurs
sur l'égide du parquet est un objectif
prioritaire avec plus de 25 réseau
démantelé en 2018
s'agissant plus particulièrement du
département de la gironde la river deux
mineurs d'origine marocaine et
algérienne en effet causer des troubles
à l'ordre public
cette arrivée est due à la modification
des réseaux de voies d'immigration en
europe qui passe désormais par l'espagne
et touche en conséquence plus fortement
des départements comme les vôtres sachez
que nous prenons ce problème très au
sérieux dès demain la préfète de gironde
rencontrera les consuls marocains et
algériens afin de mettre en place un
réseau de coopération similaire à celui
qui avait été mise en oeuvre à paris et
qui avait instauré à l'époque avec la
préfecture de police je vous remercie
merci
madame lassarade monsieur le ministre
c'était en partie l'objet de ma question
j'ai posé aussi une question sur la
santé de ces enfants à laquelle vous ne
répondez pas je vous remercie néanmoins
d'avoir pris en compte la difficulté de
ces jeunes en errance les acteurs de
terrain et les français qui sont
quotidiennement confrontés à cette
misère sont relativement rassuré de voir
amorcé un début de solution j'espère que
les élus pour être associé à ce travail
est maintenant apparaître de gironde a
d'ailleurs appelé à ce sujet mais
néanmoins merci vous êtes l'acteur n'a
osé mais les français qui sont là
collègues allemands confrontés à cette
violence attendent des actes et des
mesures concrètes merci